[Musique]
cette voix envoûtante vient tout droit
de suède isabelle sort ling ensorcellera
le public jeudi 19 et vendredi 20 mai
sur la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec son
deuxième album sorti en mai 2020 marc
held qui signifie bioluminescence en
français c'est un album qui je voulais
mélanger
un peu tous les sonorités de ce cas même
avis on peut beaucoup de revers beaucoup
d'écrans
sound skype et puis c'est mélangé avec
des rythmes
de percussions
inspiré par des musiques traditionnelles
africaines une thématique sur des
questions
essentielles pourquoi on est là c'est
quoi homo sapiens
ça parle aussi de l'amour
mme harel de ses onze titres
transcendant les genres musicaux un
appel au voyage
ce toujours chanter
est ma vie j'avais 15 ans
j'ai trouvé un guitare le piano je
commençais comme ça mes références bien
départ de la musique traditionnelle se
doit cette folk music en fichez j'ai
fait beaucoup de
musique1 progressé depuis deux ans
isabelle sort ling est en résidence ici
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est donc un aboutissement qui se
conduit par sa dernière création cet
album marc held en grand format on saura
vite que ce silence sur scène
elle
ensemble vocal saint quentin en yvelines
qui me rejoindre et puis une création
lumières sont isabelle sort lille a été
sacré artiste vocal de l'année aux
victoires du jazz 2021 elle sera jeudi
19 mai à 19h30 et vendredi 20 mai à 20
heures 30 au petit théâtre